c'est la saison des asperges en temps
normal elles devraient être récoltées
l'exploitation de louis fonctionne sur
le principe de la cueillette
les gens viennent cueillir eux-mêmes les
produits qu'ils souhaitent acheter mes
problèmes en raison du confinement
les alliés restent vides on est obligé
de fermer
j'ai beaucoup moins de fréquentation
donc j'essaye de trouver d'autres
marchés mais j'ai pu ce trafic due à la
cueillette également doit mettre en
place des nouveaux réseaux de
distribution pouvoir éviter de gâcher
ses fruits et légumes le problème que je
rencontre actuellement c'est que je suis
obligé de plaisir pour les gens les met
à disposition dans mon magasin et ça
c'est une manoeuvre que je n'ai pas
actuellement non plus et j'ai du mal à
estimer le nombre de personnes
supplémentaires qui va me falloir pour
récolter mes produits louis a tout de
même réussi à faire venir d'espagne
quelques ouvriers agricoles mais cela
n'est pas suffisant pour gérer les 38
hectares de fruits et légumes
outre les problèmes liés à la récolte
louis doit aussi préparer la terre pour
les plantations potentiellement on va
pas récolté les asperges et je veux
pouvoir débloquer donc quatre personnes
à plein temps pour écouter les asperges
afin de pouvoir planter mes tomates les
poivrons et aubergines
et tous les produits qui vont me servir
pour pour la fin de saison et la fin du
confinement quoi pour limiter la caisse
le mari chi recours au système d
par exemple ici avec les épinards voilà
à l'heure actuelle c'est très très
compliqué pour pour les ramasser déjà
les épinards c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui prend beaucoup de temps à
ramasser
donc c'est pour ça qu'on maintient on a
de la chance il fait froid à l'heure
actuelle ment donc on maintient les
serres ouvertes pour essayer de ralentir
au maximum la croissance pour espérer
avoir des épinards après la fin du
mouvement
parce que là j'ai pas à pas le passé de
main d'oeuvre tout à fait pour pour
récolter et aurait également pour
distribuer je n'ai pas également assez
de volume à distribuer
malgré tous ses efforts louis ne peut
éviter les pertes entre la main d'oeuvre
de plantation le plastique le goutte à
goutte et les pertes de chiffre
d'affaires je pense qu'on est sur une
perte à peu près de 3000 euros
je travaille dur pour trouver des
nouveaux circuits de distribution pour
essayer de cacher un minimum à mais si
j'y arrive pas il va falloir retourner
et permaculture et ça sera de la perte
sèche
autre crainte pour le maraîcher que le
confinement s'éternise au delà de
l'année mais les pertes deviendrait
alors colossal entre 50 et 60 mille
euros de produits qui ne seront pas
vendus